-Welcome back to the show.
You're in the middle of
the PGA Tour right now.
You posted this photo
that made me laugh
'cause you're traveling,
obviously.
So, you're on the plane,
and then you just took a picture
of this.
"Clubs fell out of the luggage
cart and sat there
for a few minutes
with no one in sight.
Let's just say I was freaking
out on the inside.
Here we come, playoffs."
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, talk about a nightmare.
-So you knew that -- you
recognized your clubs?
-Yeah, no, you could see
right there.
I was right on the window.
Absolute nightmare.
My heart raced.
I was sweating on the plane,
everything.
Everything was bad.
-That's a big deal.
-Yeah. That's all -- I need that
to actually play golf.
-You actually --
-So, I need my golf clubs.
-Sorry, everyone,
I just need clubs, your clubs.
But I wonder if there's
any other way to do it?
I mean, I used to bring guitars
when I used to do gigs,
and I would hopefully talk my
way into bringing it on board
and, like, putting it in
the closet in the front.
-Well, it's about -- total,
with all the shoes,
it's about 70 pounds, so...
-There was no way that's
going to happen.
-[ Laughs ]
Carry-On, yeah, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you put it
under your chair?
No, I can't do that either.
That's wild.
I just think --
It makes me laugh.
Because you're trying to
zone out.
You're like, "Dude, I want to be
in the zone."
Do you do anything special?
You're like, "Alright,
I'm playing right now.
I'm in the tournament.
I can't talk to people.
I can't have my clubs laying on
the tarmac."
-You know, for me,
it's keep everything
as normal as possible and just
treat it like a normal day.
Treat it like
a normal date night.
Treat it like a normal Friday
night, wake up, go to sleep.
-You don't have a special food
or anything?
-Nothing particular. Why?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm just saying I saw something
on the Internet I think sparked
a little bit of debate,
a little bit of controversy
if you bring it up.
-"Contrahversy"?
-Yeah.
That's how they say it overseas.
That's how they say controversy,
yeah.
-Got it.
-You're a big fan of
breakfast foods.
-Love breakfast.
-Yeah.
-Huge fan. Yeah. Love it.
Love breakfast.
Got to start the day off right.
-Alright, so you're making --
There's video of you doing this.
You're making a bowl of cereal.
-Right.
-Alright.
-Yeah.
-And here's where I get involved
and I get a little --
I almost didn't talk to you
ever again.
[ Laughter ]
You poured your milk in first,
then the cereal.
[ Audience ohs ]
There you go.
That's the reaction.
That's the reaction I want.
That's the reaction we need!
Collin Morikawa, what are you
talking about?!
-Jimmy, where do I start?
Where do I start?
Look, I mean, there's
a perfect ratio, right,
I think we all agree,
of milk to cereal.
When you put --
[ Laughter ]
-Talk to me, talk to me.
-When you put in milk first --
I wish we had a bowl. I mean,
that would just be perfect.
When you put the milk in first,
right, you pour the milk.
-Yeah.
-And then put the cereal.
-The milk doesn't splash outside
the bowl.
-Oh, how aggressive are you
pouring your milk?
[ Laughter ]
You're pouring it too hard?
-Well, when you have a gallon of
milk, I mean, it's heavy.
-Get a half gallon.
-You know, I'm an athlete,
but I'm not like a --
-Maybe you can't handle
a gallon of milk.
-I'm a small guy here.
I'm trying --
-Start with those little ones
you get in grade school.
-The little cartons of milk.
-A little carton of milk.
You don't aggressively throw
milk around.
-Hear me out. Hear me out.
Hear me out.
I think everyone's going to
try this.
-I don't. I don't.
[ Laughter ]
-When you put the milk
and then you pour the cereal,
especially like
a Frosted Flakes,
one of my favorites.
-Okay, I do like frosted flakes.
-When you put it all the way
down at bottom and it goes
all the way to the top, that is
the perfect ratio of
milk to cereal.
-But why not have cereal first,
then you can really ratio
the milk and it slowly goes in
the crevasses of
the Frosted Flakes?
-Because it splashes out
of the --
-Questlove, are you hearing
this dude?
-Yes, I am.
-And is this insane or what?
-Yeah, it's kind of weird, man.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-There's got to be one person in
here that agrees with me, right?
-Whoo!
-Yeah, there we go.
-Okay, alright. That's the
people you came here with. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That doesn't count.
What other cereals do you have?
-Oh, you know, I grew up eating
a lot of Frosted Flakes.
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, maybe if you have --
if there are flakes,
sometimes there's a little curve
on one of them if you are
aggressively pouring milk,
maybe one little dripping.
That's not going to throw off
the ratio.
-But it never happens with milk
first, then cereal.
-I think you get a little
aggressive with the cereal,
and then they sparkle
everywhere, and next thing
you know, you're pouring cereal
all over the table.
-So tell me, what happens
when you eat your cereal
and then you need to put
more cereal?
Your milk is already there?
And how good is that second bowl
of cereal?
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, now you got a point.
Now I'm starting to like
this idea.
I think legal for
the second bowl.
First bowl has got to be
cereal first, then milk.
-Just try it out.
-If you want to jump back in
and use that cereal milk, which
I do love, I'll dive back in.
But sometimes I'll --
-Try it. Try it.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it's almost -- I want
it to get a little soggy too.
I don't want it to get
completely --
-No.
-No, just a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
Now the audience is turning
on me.
[ Rimshot ]
No, no, no, no.
But wait, wait, wait, I'm
talking about high-grade cereal.
I'm talking about Grape Nuts.
[ Laughter ]
That's like eating rocks. That's
like eating rocks in a bowl.
You got to let it soften
a little bit
just for the chompers.
-That's what you do.
You pour the milk first,
cereal second.
Sits on the bottom.
Mix it up.
-Yeah, but Grape Nuts,
it's hard to do.
Hard to do with Grape Nuts
because they're so heavy
and so dense, they go right
under the milk.
You're lost. You're like,
"Help! I lost them.
I'll never see them."
It's an empty bowl.
You'll never know how many
Grape Nuts are in the milk.
-I'm going to buy you a clear
bowl so you can always see.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
There's too much --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's talk about "Full Swing."
Each episode follows different
pro golfers around
and really gets into your life
because obviously, there's much
more to the sport than
just going
and playing for the weekend.
It's gearing up.
It's your home life.
How do you do it?
How do you pour your cereal?
Things like that.
[ Laughter ]
But it got picked up
for season two.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're very entertaining.
Do you mind having the cameras
kind of invade your life,
or did you get used to it?
-You know, I think it's all part
of it.
It's kind of what we do.
You know, obviously, we have it
on the golf course
and we're pretty comfortable
with that.
But following them around,
following us around,
it took a little bit of time,
but when you really dive into
it, it's everything.
You know, and for people in the
audience and just spectators
that don't know much about golf,
who only know who Tiger Woods is
and golf is played on a golf
course, pretty obvious, right?
-Yeah.
-It's a good insight into
what we do
and learning what travel is
like.
We're traveling for about 25, 30
weeks a year, almost 35 weeks.
Sunday to Sunday.
So, put that together.
And we're doing it across
the world.
-And we get to meet your dog.
-And you get to meet our dog.
I mean, he's -- Yeah, I should
have brought him out.
-He's here.
-He is here.
-But no, keep him in the room
because he barked at me.
-He only barked at you.
No one else.
-Why, though?
-Yeah.
He doesn't like men.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what it was?
That's what it was.
Yeah, he barked at me, but then
he licked me as well.
-Yeah, he's cute.
-He was like, "What,"
like the show "What's Up?"
He's really cute.
-I think he's actually gotten
more famous
than me off the Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
-Everyone asking you about
the dog and stuff?
-We were on the plane yesterday
and someone was like,
"Oh, I actually recognized
your dog first.
And then I saw you."
[ Laughter ]
-They go, "Yeah, we forgot
your golf clubs,
by the way, but we have
your dog."
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Collin Morikawa
in "Full Swing."
Take a look at this.
-We've been at a point now
where, you know,
I hadn't won since
the 2021 Open.
And, you know, for me, so far
in my career,
it's been a long time.
Majors are career-defining.
Like yeah, you want to put on
a green jacket,
but at the end of the day, you
still want to win everything.
And Tiger won 80-something
times.
It doesn't get tiring
winning 82 times.
I mean, can I say this, I want
this one more than the others?
I mean, I want them all.
-Yeah! I want to win it all.
-I want to win.
-Collin Morikawa.
Season one of "Full Swing" is
streaming now on Netflix.
More "Tonight Show"
when we come back.